[Music]
creepy children's voices cliche two
minutes at the side of the house to make
sure everyone knows the upstairs windows
look like evil eyes Thunder scare ok now
flash the lights a couple times good no
seriously it'll look awesome when we put
in the sound effects this is a family of
the heaviest sleepers in existence how
did they not all wake up after the first
gunshot but stayed fast asleep in the
beds while he loudly shoots them one by
one reading this guy took an exorbitant
long time to speak he may be looking for
just the right words but based on what
he says it seemed more plausible that he
forgot his long ballpark guesses
insanely accurate considering that no
Mekhi ever amounted to anything in the
history of Hill Valley it could be a
guest house with a little fixing up new
windows fresh paint an exorcism
that's a wood-burning fireplace nice on
cold nights house hunters hauntings
edition barely any murders in this room
it's really the heart of your home it's
your first house we just got married
that doesn't answer the question but
nice exposition you know house is
clearly possessed by the ghost of George
Bailey we already have a family two boys
and a girl you are so bad why did he
want the realtor to think they had kids
out of wedlock the detective said that
only the mother was shot in the head but
this clearly fuck's up their story the
first person in the house drove insane
was whoever installed a dance studio in
the master bedroom
now this is genuinely creepy because I
thought my blu-ray player for us so they
knew the whole time it was a murder
house not sure why they pretended to be
so unimpressed for the realtor just go
on and get ready to move why the hell
are they so excited there are quite a
few more steps you need to take before
you actually own the house they
definitely shouldn't be celebrating
right after the walkthrough I can't even
imagine what the inspection will be like
the foundation of the house is strong
considering its age but all the walls
are filled with blood would you
something to consider no evil occurred
for one entire month also is no one ever
gonna turn off the lights in the Attic
our priest just allowed a walk into
someone's house and go anywhere they
like I feel like this is a breach of
privacy even if he hears ghostly kid
chuckles upstairs the priest doesn't
just look out the window think to
himself oh they're outside turn around
and walk downstairs why is he looking at
these two flies like they're significant
I get that the Flies signify death but
just two flies as a normal non death
amount of flies even though this is now
a more appropriate time to turn around
I'm still not sure if the Flies are
there to signify death or the sweaty
priest just smells really bad is this
guy physically incapable of running away
when a Satan house is clearly giving him
fly warnings why Laura priest upstairs
with giggling sounds if you're trying to
kick him out of the house probably could
have really spooked up the foyer you're
a man of God confronted with pretty
explicit proof of a threatening evil
then you walk away leaving the young
family behind making a mental note to
call them later this house apparently
possesses children to sleep in
uncomfortable ways matching
father-daughter shirts the murder ghosts
have the power to heat up plastic
telephone handles all the way across
town first of all her phone
troubleshooting skills are terrible
second of all our the demons possessing
the phone lines keeping them from
functioning properly or do they just
have pots lines they clearly didn't
conduct a home inspection before
purchasing the house so we'll never know
mirror Jesus pencil sharpener is mounted
on this doorway for easy access bumps
and bruises when you cut the corner into
the kitchen to close they've been in the
house a month and there's still of this
you have to avoid while walking down the
stairs this kid sucks at falling down
the stairs also a sit on his parents
we're not taking him to the emergency
room for the cuts he should have
obviously had on his hands for
bitch-slapping that lightball branded
the kid should be in bed by now but
you're doing this with an open door
is he saying she makes him vomit a kid
is an unprotected sex ghost that haunts
you for at least 18 years also they're
really lucky she was rubbing her eyes or
she may have seen something that would
scar her more than what she'll end up
seeing during this movie also did she
just open the door and gently swing it
open and immediately start rubbing her
eyes I don't know what he's so happy
about he didn't get to finish this is a
sound a cat would make if you played it
through a Casio keyboard that was being
strangled by an Atari 2600 only two
grocery bags for a family of five also I
know it's just two bags but they are
huge take two trips Kathy don't be a
hero
Kathy shouldn't be making stuff up
around her crazed husband with an axe
they aren't rolling down the block they
aren't a week's worth of groceries and
you really don't need any help did your
friend Jodi like sugar cookies too I'm
unsure of whether the imaginary friend
was a horror movie trope back then but
if this is one of the first times it's
happened I'm going to sin it for the
sheer fact that it's been in almost
every horror movie about people moving
into a new house since then there is
clearly an eyeball in the upstairs
window I'm probably gonna have a bruise
now because of how aggressively this
movie is trying to personify this house
it didn't seem like you were expecting
him seeing that you drove away in your
boat after he arrived no Amityville for
old men good news you're Murder House
struck oil also these ghosts are just
more of a nuisance than anything seems
like they're just drawing this family
it's known as the scariest thing I've
seen so far just because your aunt the
nun is visiting doesn't mean you have to
dress up like you're back in Catholic
school also does this nun need to wear
the full gear 24/7 is there not
something a little simpler for a
personal day trip why are there only
visitors clergy members but let's just
have no friends and on top of that none
of them have even bothered telling them
there's something off about your house
spiritually now I believe as soon as
possible that ship has sailed these look
like the lost BG since day one their
work should go I don't want to be up to
my ass in boxes forever this is supposed
to make him sound increasingly cold and
rude but he makes a very good point
about the stress of moving she might as
well say I was dreaming about the events
that happen in this house approximately
a year ago okay movie don't try and put
a red filter on just to distract me from
the fact that you're showing me the side
of the house for the 15th time
because this demons power extends to
cars driving down the road this horror
just went hard Tommy Boy I know the
priest has some sort of sixth sense
about flies but they're being everywhere
in general the carving up would just be
a coincidence oh he's a demon in this
house only wants to infect the father
and the daughter for some reason
everyone else the spirits in this house
want the family to leave why would they
steal this kids money if anything this
encourages them to stay and find it I
know everyone keeps commenting on how
bad George looks but if he would just
wash his hair look fine I'll take care
of him I'll write him a check
and uh what about the honeymoon I lost
that money too by the way who the fuck
is this demon it's with the babysitter
rather than simply making her sick or
telling her to leave why does this
bastard discriminate between priests the
family living there and under the table
child labor she's been locked in the
closet for less than a minute and is
already bloodying up her knuckles and
doesn't know about any malevolent
spirits we're gonna need you to calm way
down kid she cancelled checks bounced
checks is not cash I'd be worried this
guy is running a shady business that is
a front for something anyone who is this
scared of a check is probably up to no
good
it's moments like these where I feel
like I'm watching a rough cut of this
movie well then explain this keyhole
what are these spirits gonna do with
$1500 good luck trying to buy an Apple
too without a physical form asshole he
has a lot of passion for a priest who
hasn't really busted his ass to tell
these people what's going on I'd blame
Detroit a lot faster than the devil
that's Detroit us also trained priest is
unable to distinguish between Detroit
and the devil also I get the sense that
Marie Hamilton was always hired to play
the skeptic that puts people's lives in
danger and that the filmmaker saw jaws
several times before making this movie
it's always been the fashion also
covering up a haunting is only like the
sixth most dangerous Catholic Church
cover-up which is gonna walk away from
it isn't that exactly what you did after
you got bothered by some flies we can
add show off to the list of possession
symptoms the windows in this house were
built with razor blades in the kids
reaction to living in this house is
phantom blood seeing that it keeps
disappearing and reappearing no one
broken bone am I missing something
did it really slam down on him that hard
and if it did is no one questioning why
this window fell with a force much
greater than gravity I don't
you stay up here like hell yeah why
would she want to stay upstairs that's
where her own children are I checked all
the windows down in I'm broken and by I
checked all the windows he means looked
at one of them while he walked away
forever it's amazing to me that demons
and movies enjoy talking to children and
telling them their hopes and dreams for
some reason this George is just feeling
super badass because he rode his
motorcycle today why steal this library
book when you could just check it out
for free just know what I'm telling you
Jesus write a letter also did the
spirits keep Delaney from speaking and
scramble the phone that we've never seen
actually work one or the other both
seems like overkill Cathy doesn't just
pack up the kids and drive to church
just someone taking glass harp lessons
in the living room everybody wanted to
come over to welcome you to the
neighborhood
who's this everybody he's talking about
him and the miller lite this guy might
be the scariest thing we've seen so far
I'm more worried about this potential
burglaries leaned his way into their
house look just like that kid kid last
year to kill this family you know the
house down by the river does the house
only haunt people who look the same
Jodie allows Amy to sing a Bible him
without locking her in a closet it
barely tried to alter the music from the
psycho shower scene apparently Jodie is
a Jawa those fall flies at the wrong
time of year I'd argue that room
shouldn't be full of flies at any time
of year
I'm very sensitive about these things I
know about that's the great thing about
having a sixth sense regarding the
spiritual realm you can't be foolish and
no one will ever know it could have
climbed up the ivy I mean over the damn
house no it's not
what is possessing this woman to tear
down the wall all of a sudden she
absolutely did not want to go near the
house earlier did the demon who doesn't
want anyone in the house possessed her
to do this did father Delaney who
clearly doesn't want her to do this
possess her to do this I mean
kind of go through here so why the
sudden urge to break down the wall that
they come and go freely well this
obviously possessed chick proves to be
no concern to anyone in this room answer
the goddamn phone after less than eight
rings for once this is what you could
get away with an old horror movies
satanic prank calls
new homeowners should expect a little
DIY but do it yourself demon expelling
usually works best with a licensed
contractor or priest this is a really
bizarre way to blind someone good the
demon not just come in and Three Stooges
style poke him in the eyes also that's
it he stays blind forever same one isn't
God damming your house the whole problem
shouldn't you know by this point that
it's demons this is the best idea she's
had so far
sister act 3 goal tending the flock the
demons finally did it
they made father Delaney fully
transitioned to Darth Sidious certainly
is beautiful here way to rub it in
father killjoy oh there's no story to
get it right this guy basically just
summed up the entire movie charge this
must be entirely coincidental unless the
demons were all just amusing themselves
by luring a guy who looked just like the
last guy to buy the house then kill his
entire family it's a good thing Kathi
figured out George looked like that
other dude who killed his family on the
very night the devil told George to
start killing his family coincidentally
this pig creature was gonna be what
possessed Rick Moranis and Ghostbusters
but Harold Ramis had enough self-respect
to make a different choice copy down the
bathroom door and a fit of ghost induced
madness was kind of the cellphone loses
signal at crucial moment of its day was
she really in the rain long enough to
get that brownie there was no hope that
Greg would get down these stairs without
falling he can't even handle dry stairs
also I'm still not 100% on the demons
motivations here they went more dead
spirits haunting the house or do they
want them to leave they wanted him to
leave they should have just gushed blood
out of the walls on day one it's very
effective
after all it was very common for people
in the 70s to leave their keys in the
ignition in case of haunting this is the
gateway to hell and why is George just
able to climb up out of the black is
hell is just a pool of goopy black stuff
I'm not too worried about going there
anymore
end of movie reading also wait a minute
happened in this movie
George was clearly the dude who killed
his family at the beginning of the movie
and how did he get out of jail and what
made him forget about his past and what
was this demon was it Satan worshiper
John Ketchum or was it the fact that the
house was built on an Indian burial
ground and what happened to the priest
you yell Barracuda devices
you yell shark we've got a panic on our
hands on the 4th of July got a real
attitude problem and fly you're a
slacker remind me of your father when he
went here he was a slacker tool well
you're gonna be very happy it's a
wonderful house Marge Simpson sold her
first house the manor house
[Music]
I think Marvel's gonna whack again Ma
Bell I got the ill communication the ill
communication must show you this
lickable wallpaper for nursery walls
lick an orange
it tastes like an orange like a
pineapple it tastes like a pineapple
[Music]
we have in fact caught and killed a
large predator that's supposedly injured
some bathing's but it you see it's
beautiful day the beaches are open and
people having a wonderful time the walls
in the 53rd precinct were bleeding how
do you explain that